So today we're gonna be talking about fast
track to growth, leveraging partner
programs and marketplace for success.
Um, you heard all week long that
AI agents can reason, they
can plan, they can execute with increasing
autonomy.
So they're not just processing requests, they're
anticipating our needs,
they're solving complex problems. They're
taking action
alongside us
and they're opening up more think time
and more create time for us so
that we can better exercise our expertise
and focus on relationships and innovation
and this is super, super important
in the sciences, for example, you know, the
really big breakthroughs that are happening because of
AI things that couldn't happen before.
MIT researchers, for example, use
machine learning to screen over 100
million chemical compounds
to lead to the discovery of a drug called
halacin.
And what it is, is it, it kills many antibiotic
resistant bacteria, which is super important.
But the most important thing is that
we would never have discovered it without ML.
It took actually literally 3 days to do it, but
in the old world would have taken years and years and
years. But you don't
need to be an MIT researcher to see how
the AI is transforming and interacting
with the world around us.
You see
I mean, you see it all around us, right? You
see now real-time translation in dozens
of languages at a new level of accuracy.
You see educators being able to use it
to really customize learning paths for,
for students,
um, and it's not just that it can do it, but
it can do it at scale
and in near real time,
and that is really what's amazing.
And I hope that all of you are incorporating it into
your lives as well. I know that I use
QuickSuite, for example, to help me prioritize
and answer some of my email and to prepare
for customer and partner meetings.
So AI is really rewriting the
rules of what's possible.
So now we can totally reimagine
processes, outputs, and outcomes built
with agents that can learn and reason and
achieve goals autonomously.
So in this session, we're gonna explore
some of the what ifs and how they
become what's next
as we chart our path through this.
So for those of you who don't know me, my name is Julia
Chen, and I lead a function called
Specialist and Partner Corps,
and what that is, is it's all of our
programs, incentives,
strategic collaboration agreements, enablement,
um, various, uh, strategic initiatives,
and I'm very pleased to be here,
um. With my colleague Matt Yanian, he's
sitting over there, vice president of AWS Marketplace
and Partner Services,
and we really have a front row seat into
something extraordinary, which is watching
all of you, our partner community,
use the power of AI to transform
customers and their outcomes and then also
your own businesses.
So in 12 months we've not just grown
the partner community, but we've really, you
guys have really transformed how we deliver
customer outcomes.
So let me share one example.
Trellix
is a global cybersecurity company and they had a
problem.
So security operations teams
were facing overwhelming volume
of daily alerts that required extensive
manual processing.
Um,
Trellix was actually able to transform
their cybersecurity operations by leveraging
Amazon Bedrock and Amazon Nova
to analyze
1000 daily security alerts
in just 30 seconds.
And it used to take them
80 hours,
so that's huge.
Not only did it reduce their time, but it also
reduced the investigation costs as
they're related.
So it's super inspiring to see what
we've been able to accomplish together
and we're just getting started.
So during the keynote that you heard from
Matt Garman, Swami, and Ruba about our
latest innovations that are gonna
help you fast track your growth,
and I hope you guys were as excited as I
was to hear about them.
Some things don't change though, so the technology
is changing fast, but our vision remains
unchanged,
and that is to make AWS the best
place to build market, sell, and
grow. Today Matt and I
are gonna be diving into the transformative era
that we're entering with Gen AI and
AI agents.
We're gonna share our perspective
on how you can better position your own businesses
to really thrive in the AI era
and how best to leverage our partner programs
and accelerate growth and differentiate
your offerings.
We'll also highlight the latest AWS
marketplace innovations designed to help you
deliver solutions faster and create
new revenue streams.
Are you ready?
Awesome.
It seems like every year, it's almost cliche
at this point. Every year we say the pace of
innovation is accelerating,
and I'm gonna say it again because it is,
and this year it's faster than ever.
According to Gartner,
Gen AI spending is gonna reach $644
billion.
But it's just, it's not just that absolute
number that's incredible, it's actually the growth rate
76.4%
year on year growth is incredible.
Like we don't see those kind of growth rates on, you
know, sort of quote unquote traditional tech.
So, in 2025, we
AWS have released dozens of
major Gen AI services and future launches
across all different layers of the AWS
AI stack from our purpose-built
chips
to frontier models to
applications and also to developer tools.
Um, because we've said in the past 3 years
the partners who deliver business outcomes
now are accelerated with all of these different AI
tools and they will earn the highest margins.
Why do they earn the highest margins?
So some of you guys who've been to this talk
in years past recognize this slide.
This slide has actually not changed for
4 different reinvents. So it's been
the same slide, and every, and it's not
because every year I don't question whether the
the slide should change,
but actually because.
It's still valid, right? Like I've
not found a counter example to this.
Delivering business outcomes is more
differentiated and unlocks more business
value than reselling AWS services
alone. Our commitment to accelerating
your journey, no matter where you are on
this path remains.
So we want to make our programs simple,
predictable, and profitable.
Some days we do better than others,
but we're always striving towards that
and today AI is increasing the
value of the business out. Outcomes
and so the margin difference now,
so the bottom is resell, right? Services,
managed services, tech solutions, business
outcomes.
The gap in profitability is actually getting
bigger
because the Gen AI and the agentic AI
is helping those business outcomes become even more
valuable.
We'll talk about some data around that as well.
So partners are seeing higher profitability
when they invest in 3 different areas.
So the first is expanding your range
of services to customers.
So there's lots of different services that you can
provide to customers and you do, right? It's
advisory services, it's integration
services, it's implementation, migration,
modernization,
management of their infrastructure,
um, and support, to name a few.
The second one is around AI adoption.
And you'd have to have been asleep the whole week
if you hadn't picked this one up, but it's super, super
important both for the customer solutions but
also for your own running of your own
internal business. This is super critical.
And the third one is by leveraging AWS
Marketplace to really scale your
transformational offerings.
So partners that take advantage of all three
of these things are gonna grow faster
and get higher profitability.
The math is super compelling.
Our highest performing partners
can now earn $7.13
in revenue for every $1 of AWS
customers spend.
So that's up from $6.40
in 2022 thanks a lot
to AI.
And this is what's really exciting. We know that 82%
of our partners are already delivering
AI solutions and 73%
of you guys are using AI to transform
your own business,
and there's many ways that partners can
deliver business with uh deliver
value with AI
and I wanna share a few with you.
You have the poorest communities living
next to the most endangered species
in the world.
And we expect them to
protect those species whilst receiving
no reward
whatsoever
for their stewardship. AWS
was incredibly helpful in starting
this revolutionary process
of representing
what the needs of a particular species might
be. Tehanu
is the bridge between
conservation and community
development.
Our mission is to impact
communities by providing them
with an extra source of income
while protecting endangered species.
Working with Ad Astra and
Anthropic provided an incredible
solution. When you tried to work out
what were the basic needs of those
animals, boil those down into
simple tasks that. be acted
upon by human agents.
We take a huge amount of scientific
papers and data and
we extract what are the actual needs
that the gorillas have.
The AI is able to really
look for all the niche information and find
very specific recommendations and
what possible actions could be taken
to increase their life outcomes.
Anthropic's great accuracy and performance
makes it easy
to Monitor the behavior and
deploy it.
We managed to build a payment platform.
It starts with the species.
The species gets a digital identity.
The animal has a piggy bank and it's
going to pay you a few coins
if you do something that it really
needs. One example would be
a ranger removing
a snare, taking a picture, and
then send it, and after validation,
the ranger will actually receive money
directly into their mobile money. Account
AI for good
means taking all the powerful tools that we have
now and using them to
help protect other species, extend
biodiversity, help preservation,
and also help people in
need. The work that Tejano
Anthropic Adestra and AWS did
combines all these things together. It's
an incredibly exciting future
to imagine that we have AI
partners to help us
better protect other species on the planet.
So I was personally very inspired by
that video. So after I watched that, and I hope you
guys are as well, um,
leveraging Adastra's AI expertise
and really the comprehensive cloud solutions
of AWS, Tehanu is really
pioneering AI for wildlife
preservation.
Um, Adastra had to create a solution from scratch
using Amazon Bedrock, Amazon S3,
and AWS Lambda to fine tune
this AI
for wildlife conservation.
They had extensive data on mountain
gorillas and they were correlating that
um to documents and papers that
had been, you know,
research papers that have been done
and all of that had to come together.
But what's very important is that in order
for all of that to be, you know, correlated
and available to the AI it all had to be
in one place in modern infrastructure, modern
databases, etc.
So, um, this cloud-based infrastructure
enabled them to process behavioral data
110 times faster than
human experts.
So what used to take 24 hours
actually got reduced down to 13
minutes with 93% accuracy.
So that, I mean, scales, it's amazing and
especially in these far remote places where you don't
have a lot of resource and you don't have a lot of
humans to do this work, the time
really matters.
So, importantly,
Tehanu's approach uses technology to create
this bridge, right, between wildlife conservation
and economic development. And I think I
love that because it's a win, win, win
situation. And then you also
see how migration and modernization
together are really important to unlock the
full value of the AI.
So our ambition because you know this is going
to migration and modernization
is around increasing the modernization
service attached to your migrations
because that's really how you unlock the value
of the AI.
It's also migrating specialized workloads
that disproportionately feed business
outcomes and I'll dive into some of those specialized
workloads in a minute.
Um, and to also drive a relentless
focus on the value realization of,
of the migrations that you've done.
So it wouldn't be a program talk if I didn't talk
about MAP.
OK, so as a recap, the migration
acceleration Program is one of our largest
programs, and it serves two purposes.
It's a structured methodology for taking
a customer through a migration, and
it's also a funding program that helps
our customers with the upfront migration
costs.
Last year we enhanced MAP to be even
more streamlined and partner friendly.
We streamlined the funding approvals and
we accelerated payments and we expanded
support for for new to cloud customers.
The results that we saw were really, really good actually.
Our customers have been reaching their first
migration milestone 41%
faster,
so that's, um, I mean it's
partly due to the program, but it's very much
due to you guys. So thank you very much for doing that
work. Hundreds of
partners have achieved the migration competency
designation so that you can access the MAP
program and if you haven't, please look into it,
um, and we will continue to add tools
into the migration toolkit
so that you can do it more seamlessly and, and
quicker. This
is one example. So with our experience based
accelerator, we train your teams
to help customers build the organizational readiness
that they need for successful migrations.
Another way that we help customers accelerate
migrations is through Countdown premium.
It provides customers with immediate
access to an engineer,
um, across a range of services,
whether it beerless, database, AI, SAP,
whatever you need.
So instead of the customer opening tickets
and you know someone dealing with one-off tickets,
the same engineer will stay with the, with
the customer and that way they have all the context
that they need and they're able to resolve things faster.
So not only do we want our customers
to migrate and modernize so they can leverage the benefits
of AI for their business problems,
but we also want to use it to speed up the migration
itself. So we
have worked with several third party ISPs
that have tooling River Meadow, Monty Cloud,
Concerto, Matilda Cloud, you see them on the slide.
There's also many others as well that didn't fit
onto the slide,
but they have tools actually that
are available to you that help speed up migrations
and in some cases AWS will help subsidize
your use actually of their tools.
We've also launched AWS Transform
and you heard a bit about that as well with a lot of really
cool new features, so definitely
check that out. It's a new agentic migration
and modernization service
for enterprises.
It combines three powerful AI
technologies LLMs, graph
neural networks, and automated reasoning
to make it much easier and faster to migrate
and modernize and transform critical
workloads at scale.
So, you know, taking
Cobalt code and then turning it into
um Java.
It really results in a lot of time savings.
So for example, TCS, a global IT
firm, used AWS Transform to modernize
their customers' entire state
of 3000 VMs and saw
amazing results.
So they got to 95% accuracy
and 45 to 60% productivity
gains.
And map in the Gen AI era really
includes now modernization with Gen AI and
agentic features for your existing
applications, data, and workloads.
So let's get to these mission critical workloads
that we believe need to be prioritized.
So, um,
Tehanu, for example, probably wasn't using enterprise
software,
but I know that many of your customers do.
And every customer starts from a different place, but
one thing is constant, which is that a lot of
these critical workloads Windows, SAP,
VMware
actually perform better on AWS.
They can run more efficiently, scale more easily.
One example that we have is that SAP
Rise actually runs faster on
AWS.
So it's um it actually
uh we get 58% fewer disruptions
and 30% faster performance
running on AWS doing analytics.
Another example is Microsoft workloads. So
since 2008, we've been helping customers
reduce their operating costs by
an average of 39% when
it runs on AWS versus running on-prem.
Also helping our customers modernize their .NET
applications to .NET Core and from SQL
Server to AWS databases actually offers
two key benefits. It saves your
customers some licensing costs,
but it also enables them to use other AWS services
later like Bedrock and all the future
innovation that keeps coming.
Let's talk for a minute about VMware.
So according to analysts, 80% of companies
have an upcoming VMware contract event,
a renewal event in the next 24 months,
and 74% of customers are evaluating
alternatives
to their VMware workloads.
Amazon Elastic VMware service,
um, can help customers unlock the benefits
of AWS at scale.
Um, so this is something that you definitely want to
look into because it'll give your customers greater
control and agility, um, if they're
looking for alternatives to VMware.
It's something that you wanna have a conversation uh
about early on
so don't just take it from me. We have,
um, partners and customers feeling the same way
and here's a quote
from um from Aeromexico.
Another area that's gotten a pretty big boost from
AI is around managed services. So
you'll see me get really, really excited about
managed services, and you guys remember from
the partner profitability framework slide that I
showed, managed services is, you know, higher
up on the stack.
Uh, the data is actually very compelling internal
and external data that we have.
By 2026, MSPs
will manage 65% of cloud
service provider spending, so that's $443
billion.
But what's interesting,
especially interesting, is actually why
our research shows that partners working
with validated AWS MSPs
deliver 3 times faster customer
growth
because they're trusted advisors. It makes a lot of sense
and a lot of you actually are managed service providers I
know and so you are the trusted advisor
of the customer. You.
Day in and day out in their environment
you can spot things that they need and
that gives you an opportunity to really help
them advance faster
so that's why we're doubling down on our
investment in MSP partners and
for the first time offering monetary incentives
for managed services
and we have a couple of programs launching throughout
2026.
We have the MSP Incentive for Customer Management
that focuses on partners managing ongoing
customer operations and retention on
AWS.
Later next year we'll be launching the MSP
Incentive for Strategic Services focused
on partners delivering customer adoption
of high value AWS capabilities
like Gen AI,
like security, and other things as well.
And then we have an MSP government
practice benefit for those of you who work a
lot in public sector that support
partners that are serving government and education
customers particularly.
So let's hear from Cap Gemini's
experience with our managed service program.
As one of the key cloud providers,
Cap Gemini provides end to
end services for cloud. The AWS managed
service program has helped Cap Gemini
business through the training,
through the technical support, through the
access to technical architects
that we get, the employees. On
the G Gemini side have been able to
work with the financial services clients better. It
has helped us be more competitive in the market.
It has helped provide better solutions
or more cost
effective solutions to clients
and has helped with the right pipeline
revenue as well as
great joint big deals and wins
through access to all the.
Expertise as well as the
funding support by collaborating with AWS
on the minor services program, we
have close to achieved
close to 15 to 20% cost savings
just because of the support in
terms of the right technical solutions, faster
time to market, as well as
through the support and funding, which
helps us provide better
customer service to our clients.
So as you just saw, Cap Gemini achieved
higher profitability and we're able to cut costs,
um, as they were trusted advisors to
their customers.
Um, so this is the MSP advantage,
you know, in action, and we're gonna more and more
reward that.
So let's go back again to AI.
82% of partners are delivering AI
solutions. I'd said that at the beginning and really
integrating them into their into your,
I should say, processes and delivery.
So, um,
we're seeing that that actually pays off quite
a lot. Um,
we're seeing the biggest profitability bump
actually, um, in this area of
all the partner categories surveyed,
and we want you all in the room to really benefit
from this as much as possible.
So AI is sort of sprinkled everywhere
throughout and so throughout this talk you're gonna be hearing
how, how it plays into, into every part
of it. So,
um, I urge all of our resellers
to continue building up your services and your services
will be enhanced by AI.
There's a couple of different changes to our channel
partner programs.
I don't have time to get into them in great detail,
but this you will find some of it in, in
Partner Central, and we will continue to keep rolling out
webinars and office hours and various
different things. But to go over them quickly,
we're streamlining our base benefits.
So, um,
let's see, this is, this is going to be
more simplification, predictability, and earnings
and reduced overhead for you guys.
Um,
the base benefit consolidates our previous base
benefit and the technical capability discount
that used to be two separate things we're putting them
together. We also have a new customer
incentive, and this is not so
new customer incentive is not necessarily a new thing.
We've had it in various different flavors, but we're actually combining
it to be one thing now so that
that will be more simplified.
There's a partner growth incentive. So again,
we've had many flavors of
account growth, different levels of growth like
you guys are familiar with PGD, POD, various
flavors of that.
We're also consolidating all that into a partner
growth incentive at the portfolio level
for your resell portfolio.
And over time it'll expand to revenue
under management, but for 2026 it'll be
just your resell portfolio here
for this one.
And then we also have deal registration that we're
introducing for the first time for
more control and transparency
along with higher incentives and enhanced billing capabilities.
We're also excited to launch the partner Greenfield
program to help our partners build their Greenfield business
practice by scaling up AWS
capabilities and focusing on new
customer engagement in three priority areas
so migration, modernization, Gen AI,
and security.
Um, this program is gonna give you more coal
support, enablement, and resources to help our
partners to build their practice and
clear milestones and shared metrics.
OK, so we'll hear from Copa Airlines because
I wanna talk a bit about our ISV incentives
as well. In brea Garcia director so idatos
paraco coparlands erhua
aolinia er panamena
que viaja, uh, trentao paise
genescincociades
yaido la aolinia ma
punt de Latino America
porter serena consecumundat warehouse
queeramuikotosoer
incremental la capacida not any.
implement analytic real time Amazon Web Services. parabis
para stasian
marketplace pots.
Amazon. I
love that video
so I mean we're all about partnering
and by the way like it's um like we're
seeing a lot more multipart solutions
coming together and I definitely wanna encourage that as
well but like you see
uh Copa Airlines, they were very happy with the
solution that they got and had enormous time savings
from the solution that was put together.
So we want to continue to enable
you so it's not just about programs it's about
all the different things partner equips game
days, webinars, trainings, and you
have to keep telling us and giving us feedback on
what it is you need to make sure
that you're getting what you, um, what you need
to learn as well as, uh, what you need in terms of
funding. So we give innovation and sandbox
credits to partners so that they can try things and experiment
for free,
um, and we've recently held our first ever
AI agent global hackathon.
Um, Swami, uh, Swami
had talked about it as well, so, um, we
had over 9500 developers from
over 127 different
countries build over 600 projects
using Amazon AI tools like Bedrock,
SageMaker, and Kiiro.
Our first place winner, um, that
you've heard was Ajito Nelson, so I'll just
feature him one more time.
Um, and his project was an
AI agent called Ecolahaic
that tracks waste management in Timor-Leste
using Amazon Bedrock and Agent
Core. So again, this is another story that
I love which is that he's able to democratize
the AI and actually make it so that
every single person
that had the app could take a picture of
waste. And be able to um
the app would would allow anybody to actually
report uh report and get the severity
of the of the pollution problem which is amazing
because then authorities could come in prioritize
and clean it up
it's really really cool
so I hope that you guys and all of your teams are
using this and experimenting with it because
truly the sky's the limit on what you can do with
these great tools.
All right, so please do win. This is the QR code in
case you wanna see more of the different
um projects that there were. There were so
many amazing, really inspirational projects,
and so you should take a look in case you didn't get a
chance to look at the various, uh, the various
projects that were submitted.
These are really like when I talk about business outcomes,
right? It's really cool to see the business outcomes that
people come out with.
All right.
Speaking of business outcomes, the main program
supporting business outcomes right now is called Box.
It really empowers our partners to deliver
exceptional customer outcomes through
multi-product solutions and collaboration
opportunities.
So we've, uh, Box is not new,
and it's already helped over 350
new solutions come together.
And you know what, we were able to generate,
uh, and co-sell
50 quality opportunities that converted
to 20%.
So this is really. Really good impact and
so we're gonna continue expanding Box.
Um, it's gonna have
more enhanced account planning, marketing
support, funding for industry specific use cases.
It's gonna strengthen the co-sell,
um, with us and then also it'll, um,
it'll improve seller visibility visibility
so it'll be more visible to our, our internal
CRM users.
So these improvements are gonna help partners to
better serve the line of business which I know
is a priority for, for all of us.
I will go through some of our other uh
ISV programs quickly. So we
have the workload migration program.
Um, so workload migration program, also
not a new program, has been around for some
time. But some of the new enhancements
to it are that you're gonna be able to now offer
credits to existing customers. This is, this
is new. Previously had not been there
before and simplified ARR calculations
and tooling.
So I hope that that will help all of you guys to help
migrate, um,
to migrate workloads from anywhere basically
onto AWS.
All right. And then our ISV accelerate
program, also not a new program, has been around
for, for quite some time.
Um, it's really the powerhouse behind
our cosell engine with ISVs.
So what makes it special is our AWS sales
teams get to retire quota and they get compensation
to co-sell with you.
Your solutions are also featured in our internal
recommendation engine and, um,
and it really, you know, many of you guys who
are in this program tell me it makes a big difference
to motivate our sellers to work with you.
So that um we will continue
to expand that actually.
Um,
we expanded this last year. It was marketplace
only, but we expanded it almost 10-fold
and allowed 10 times more ISPs
onto the program.
And then also, um,
uh, sorry, and I'll skip now to Marketplace
private offer promotion program.
So this actually we're gonna expand
by quite a lot.
Uh, we dramatically expanded it uh with
end to end automation that delivers credits
within one business day of offer acceptance,
which is fantastic. We know that speed matters when
you've got a deal on the table and so this automation
should help you win more deals.
We also have two additions to MPOP.
Now we have an MPOP Activate
to support new marketplace sellers, including
qualified global startup participants
that are in their first year or in their 1st
20 private offers.
We also have for all of the veterans MPOP
Grow, which, um, which
provides established partners with ongoing
support covering 20% of marketplace
contract value with an additional 0.5%
on select agentic AI products.
So looking ahead to Q1 2026
because we have an exciting roadmap coming up, we're
introducing product level eligibility
in our automated partner funding tool to help
ensure we're investing in solutions that are deployed
on AWS.
And we know that success in the cloud is
not one size fits all, and we always
wanna meet you where you are
and so please keep telling us where you are
in your journey and we've got the tools and if
we don't have them, we'll make them
um the tools to help you along your AWS
partner journey.
Um, but to truly scale this impact, we
need to transform how our customers discover,
buy, and consume technology,
and this is where AWS Marketplace comes in,
and I'd like to invite Matt up to the stage because he's
gonna tell you all the magic on Marketplace.
Nice. Hi.
Yeah, let me reiterate,
thank you for being here on the Thur I think
it's, is it Thursday?
Does everyone else have that eye twitch at this stage?
Yes, yeah, I'm, I'm with you.
Um, so I, I guess I'm one
of the last things that stands between, uh,
between you and the replay party. I hope to see you
on the dance floor last night. I saw a couple of you at
the mission, uh, party last night. I
did an Irish exit though, pretty, which I can say because
my wife is Irish,
um. So my name is Matt Yanian.
I lead AWS Marketplace and partner services,
and,
uh, it does sound a bit cliche, a bit like,
uh, you know what Julia was saying before,
but it, it's true. I am so excited
to be here this year. I, I've been at AWS for 13
years, but I've been in this role for about 3,
3.5,
and this is really the year when we delivered a
lot of things
that so many of you have been asking for for both marketplace
and partner center.
And the other services that we launched. It's, uh,
it's been really validating for the team.
Uh, if you saw the partner Kino with Ruba,
I had the privilege of, of joining her for a few minutes
and doing a demo of some of the new features,
and it just felt good for my team, you know,
they, they put their blood, sweat, and tears in often
over Thanksgiving weekend to get these
features to you.
And uh
and now they're real and we're getting great feedback
and hopefully you're seeing that your feedback matters
and you're seeing that feedback
reflected in our roadmap whether it's in
Partner Central with the APIs and I'll talk
about it. I've been joking that Graviton 5
and Training 3 ain't got nothing on Partner Central 3.0,
um, but uh, you know, keep giving
that feedback because we're moving quickly. We've
shipped 27% more features year to date.
Uh, thanks to AI enhancements, uh,
we can do more, and we've been doing a lot of foundational
work that you don't see, so we can deliver more
things more quickly to you. So today I'm gonna talk
about some of those new things,
uh, on both the marketplace side and the partner
services side,
but really this is, if anything, the takeaway
should be a call to action.
You know, I want you to use these features
but provide feedback on what we should do next.
So if you do nothing else,
just start thinking about how you're gonna pin
me after this session and tell me what
you really need to take your growth to the next
level. Our
vision remains the same.
Uh, it's just an expanded vision now. We want
to meet customers where they are
and really have everywhere
or marketplace everywhere that customers are.
Uh, you saw us start to do this with things like buy with
AWS last year and we're now up to, I think,
18 different AWS service console integrations,
uh, but we're really just getting started.
And meeting customers everywhere isn't just
in an AWBS service console or a third
party catalog. It's also reducing
procurement friction and meeting them in the tools
that they use every day, whether it's sales
tooling or an ERP or a CRM or
any type of procurement tool. It means
putting marketplace in the right places for
the right personas that need to discover
and procure through the marketplace and making it easy to
use. So that's sort of a theme and a thread
that runs through everything we're doing.
We really took an intentional step even
organizationally actually to to reorganize
both the features and our own team around the buyer
journey this year
so you, you see the features and the program enhancements
and so much else we've been doing map that that
separation from discovery helping customers
find what you want and we'll talk about AI search and
agent mode and other things that we've rolled out there
through to
trying before you buy.
If you're a partner, if you're selling software in
particular, you'll know that something like a
free trial,
uh, some type of ability for the customer
to try before they buy is critical to increasing
conversion rates and also for customer happiness.
So we're putting a lot of effort into the research
phase, whether that's due diligence that might go into an RFQ
or an RFP or the actual trying
it. We have a pilot right now with a demo
you might have seen powered by, um,
what's it called? Workspace Studio
to uh actually help you.
Try a full blown demo of the product
before before you buy on the back of other features we
have like free trials for a long time, so a lot of effort
around evaluation
and then streamlining purchasing
we wanna maintain this tension with marketplace where
it's disruptive where we're pushing the
industry to new and exciting places in terms
of speed of procurement and that means, you
know, doing some things in new ways, but it also
means being the new normal and working with
normal procurement processes that that need to happen
in any company of any size so
we love that tension we love.
You know, working with the tools and the process that you have today,
but kind of nudging us all forward
into the future and, and sort of riding that tension.
And a big theme in the last couple of years and
especially the launches that I'll cover today is that it doesn't
end at subscribe.
Once you buy something and purchase something,
there's actually research from Gartner that says that 25%
of SASS purchases never get used or rarely
get used, and I actually think that's pretty conservative.
Just think of your own company.
There's license licenses littering
all of our companies, right, for unused SASS subscriptions.
So it's not limited to SASS first of all, but
we, we're putting a lot of effort into how can we increase
buyer retention, renewal rates, etc. and
really just customer happiness by.
Taking it after subscription and setting things
up and like increasing the the value
of what you bought and discovered through the marketplace.
So let's go through some of these features.
The bottom line is that when we think about the procurement
phase, if we solve the problems faster
and if we close deals more efficiently, it will mean that you'll
be able to grow more global businesses
more quickly.
Less friction for customers means more business
growth and faster velocity. We wanna be
the most strategic channel for partners
to, to sell their software,
professional services, and data
in the cloud.
We, we've made a lot of progress, but like I said, there's
still work to do, so please bring your feedback to us.
So first of all with discovery I mentioned that we
we segmented both the features that we build and also even
organizationally around the buyer journey,
uh, you know, helping customers show up in the first
place to discover your product, helping our reps
discover what product they wanna co-sell
with you is critical. So we put a lot of
effort into what we used to call buyer
features, but it's not just buyers, it's, uh, really
just the first phase of the, the discovery
and you'll know that search historically
wasn't necessarily the top strength of Marketplace.
That's Matt being polite
as a Canadian.
Uh, you know, we, we rolled out type
of head search and I was on stage, um,
talk, telling you how great typehead search, and everyone was like,
welcome to 2000.
So, uh, now we have, uh, AI
powered search which, uh, is actually great. It's
wonderful. It does things that you expect honestly as a
buyer these days, things like AI powered summaries
at the top of the results that help you make,
uh, to quickly understand what you're about to see.
And something feedback from you was that the ranking,
uh, could be improved. So actually the search ranking has
been totally
we ripped it out and replaced it. We're using actually multiple
AI models and search algo.
For example, we're using coherent re rank to help
with our search results. We're also using
cloud all through Bedrock
to help generate those AI summaries. We use Nova
Premiere as well
for search, so we're multimodal. It all goes
through Bedrock,
but we've improved our search across a number of vectors.
We have AI generated categories, so it's no longer
just fixed categories, it's dynamic categorizations.
A number of
improvements to search that aren't immediately obvious,
but what will be obvious is that you can find more
relevant results more quickly.
And if you're a seller,
hopefully your, your solutions get surfaced
a lot better in, in more relevant
ways to buyers.
So a lot of people have been talking about agent mode this week,
but don't forget
that AI powered core fundamental search
is a big change.
Agent Mondo is, is getting a lot of buzz and rightly
so. So if you go to the ADBS Marketplace
page, if you get tired of listening to me, just pull it up on your phone.
Um, you can see there's a brand new
agent mode experience and what agent mode is is
a personalized conversational search
experience for discovering products.
And this is really important because say you have like detailed
requirements like an RFP
or uh technical requirements or just a
list of stuff that you want.
Now you can upload that document. It could be like a PDF
document and we use
anthropic cloud through Bedrock to parse your
requirements and then auto generate AI
powered product comparisons on demand.
What's cool about these product comparisons is
that they incorporate first party data, and by that
I mean AWS data with third party
data that we license from providers like Q2 and others,
uh, with real-time insights from the web
and if you use something called Nova Web Grounding,
which is a service that you can access through Bedrock,
uh, it can actually go ahead and get, it's like Rag, it can go ahead
and get real-time insights on the web.
So we pull in real-time data
in addition to the data provided via the LLM, in
addition to third party data and our own data,
and we pull all that together and we make a dynamic.
Comparison that corresponds to the requirements
that you either typed in natural language or that you
uploaded,
so it's more than just like
these aren't static requirements.
We had AI powered product comparisons that I'll show
in a second that was sort of phase one
and we had AI powered search that we rolled out with
the AI agents and tools launch at uh at
New York Summit in July, but this is a whole new
thing real-time insights, third party
data, first party data.
How many of you have ever bought software ever in your life
for, for a company? Like, I hope so, you're here.
Um. What, what does
your boss normally say?
Are you getting a good price?
Did you look at the other options? Like, are you sure it's
gonna work, uh, etc. So
we're, we're trying to help you answer those questions
more quickly and whether that is a formal
procurement process or just like your boss
needling you to make sure that you're not getting ripped off,
you need a set of information, right?
And that takes time.
And candidly, what are most people doing? They're going on a Google
or a cloud in their pocket and they're doing that research, so
we're bringing it into the marketplace and putting more structure
around it and giving you information that you can trust
so you can make informed buyer decisions.
There's this thing we talk a lot about internally called buyer's
regret.
There's a lot of buyer's regret out of there or people
that don't do due diligence and then they
buy something and guess what? Like Gartner says, it
sits on the shelf.
So we wanna help you make better buying decisions so you get
better value
out of what you subscribe to and what you buy and to do
that you need data.
Third party data, 1st party data, real-time
data from the from the web, and that's what we pulled together
in agent mode.
Again, if you get bored of looking at me,
open your pocket. I hope you have Anthropic cloud, the
app. If you have the pro version, you can add the AWS
Marketplace. A connector,
it's available today already and you
can run the agent mode via our MCP server from
cloud directly or any any
AI tool that supports MCP.
So you can use our website to run agent mode or
any AI tool that supports MCP that's available
today already.
Pretty cool because guess what our data already shows
that yes, we're still getting a lot of organic traffic from
uh search results. We're getting a ton of organic traffic
from AI tools.
So now you have first party connectors that
hit our MCP servers that use agent mode and you get
the same third party reviews with the stars,
the product comparisons, in any tool of your choice.
I said this on LinkedIn, if you follow what we call
Matt's roadmap LinkedIn,
you'll see that it's true. This is a glimpse into the future of
procurement. Just
to drill a little bit deeper, uh, there's more
than just the, the, the, the
requirements parsing. We have AI powered
product comparisons and that pulls in, we have 1st and
3rd party reviews.
Uh, we have AI powered, uh, product
review summaries.
And something that kind of flew under the radar but is super
important is AI powered pricing insights.
If you've ever used an enterprise software
product, sometimes the pricing is a little confusing.
There's a lot of different dimensions that you're priced
on, and sometimes it's hard to understand.
I mean, how, how many of you ever in your, in your life received
a bill for a software product that was like, Oh,
didn't think I'd
be charged like that. Oh, all right, gotta go to
talk to my boss now. We wanna help you
understand so you don't have to have that conversation with your boss.
That's what uh pricing insights is. It helps you
make sense of the dimensions and how they translate
translate into what you're actually gonna pay for.
So we're really trying to simplify things
and you know with the AI powered
translations as well you can see this stuff in
Japanese or French or you know the language of your
choice as well. So we wanna take that
information, distill it for you, present it in the form
that you will best consume it with,
and uh yeah, help you make that informed buying
decision. So
that's how you find what you buy, but
what about what you buy?
So
multi-product solutions is something that
candidly is overdue.
Many of you in the room have asked me for this for
years, and I can't be
happier to deliver this. We,
this is something that seems so simple, but it's actually very
complex. I'll give you some
potentially boring unless you're like me and you love tax
reasons why this is complex. Um,
professional services like people services are taxed
differently in most countries than software.
And the way that companies,
uh, I see some of my friends here, you know, selling
enterprise license agreements, for example, that makes things
complex. You're not necessarily selling a SKU
per product, you're putting SKUs together. Um,
the way that buyers buy and sellers
sell for complicated enterprise
products can be, can be complicated. So modeling
these as multi-product solutions,
uh, is, is not trivial.
What if you're buying through a reseller? What if you're buying
professional services and that that company
is reselling a bunch of one or more product vendors?
Who's the lead seller? So we had to think through a lot of
things to get this done
and I'm really proud of what the team has delivered. What
this is is multi-product solutions,
but in reality it's actually taking multiple SKUs
and putting it in a single container. I like to
think of it like a container,
a single product listing.
And it's not just like an ad. It's not just
like a, a static web page that we stuffed
SKUs together.
First of all, it's a, it's, it's an actual AWBS
product listing that we can flow through the same
recommendation systems that we use for individual
listings today. So this is critical
because what do we do as an enterprise sales force
today? We sell solutions now.
Many of you have sales forces, and that's, that's been the
thing for years. You're selling industry-based solutions, use
case-based solutions, horizontal solutions to
solve specific customer problems. Now
you can do that through the marketplace
instead of selling.
As a security solution you can sell
a zero trust security solution targeted for
global financial services institutions in the United States
and model that as a multi-product solution.
You can have one or more vendors.
And one or more products. This could be software software
software, software services software
from end vendors.
The way it works today it's modeled with a lead seller,
uh, and each
offer is still a separate SKU, so we
handle that different taxation and different
sometimes benefits associated with them
behind the scenes.
It's dramatically simplifies the customer
experience because they can accept one offer set and we
take care of setting out those different offers to the different
sellers automatically.
So for the customer it makes it easier to manage things.
They don't have to kind of manage.
You still have to sign contracts with the different vendors,
or rather sign different offers corresponding to
the different vendors,
but we greatly simplify it for the customers so
you can close that deal faster.
But most importantly, it unlocks solution-based selling
in a more meaningful way for all of you.
So this is huge and it actually unlocks a lot of other
side challenges that I've heard from
partners
in terms of how you wanna create packages of offerings
together so this is.
Maybe not so quietly, one of our more
significant launches,
and I think there's already 69
or 71 listings live,
and I expect to see dozens if not hundreds
more in the coming weeks.
Here's some examples just to sort of make it real.
I was on stage talking about, uh, uh,
uh ZScaler ZPA plus MCP
server plus Presidio professional services offer.
Uh, there's a great one from Accenture with Elastic,
for example, with an MCP server.
some of the many services that are out there.
These are different permutations, but you can do really
any kind of combination.
If you squint and look closely at the slide, you'll see something
near the bottom that's kind of interesting too. What is it? Anyone
guess? What's connect?
That third party Connect? No, that's an AWS service.
Now there are AWBS service listings in Marketplace
as well.
Connect
professional services we have MCP servers,
uh, we have QuickSuite.
You're gonna see more AWS services
now these are listings they're not transacted
any differently. You still buy them the same way you always did
like you when you click that, you go to the Connect console and
you pay for it on your AWbase bill like usual,
but this is important because it allows you to create packages
that are both 3rd party, 3rd party, 3rd
party, or 3rd party, 3rd party
AWS.
So what if you had expert delivery implementation services
plus
Box, for example, plus QuickSuite.
Now QuickSuite can have a box connector
delivered to you by Deloitte. I just made that up,
but that, that's a good example.
So now you can start to think the gears can start to turn. What
combinations can you do to meet customers' needs
of 1st and 3rd party professional services
plus software. The possibilities are kind of endless.
I mentioned that I think of the multi-product solution
as a container
and that we use it for recommendations. This is
important because internally
we also
use algorithms and models to recommend
the best partner solutions to our reps
to sell.
We use a CRM from our friends at Salesforce
internally
and we have thousands and thousands of customer
opportunities.
And I try, my, one of my goals in life is for every
single one of those customer opportunities to have a partner
product or products attached to it.
And we recommend which partner solutions
to attach
automatically.
In every single customer opportunity at at AWS
and now we can recommend
packaged multi-product solutions that are really specific
to that customer
directly to the customer opportunity so that increases
co-sell, increases the number
of AOs, Amazon originated opportunities, and
ultimately
better leads so you can create
these packages that will result in
better co-sale and better visibility of your solutions
across customer opportunities in our CRM for all
of our global reps.
So better leverage the power of go to market.
We're I'm just getting started there.
Match vision, Matt's vision is simple. I want completely
unbiased recommendations
that attach your solutions to every single
customer opportunity with high precision and
no bias.
I wanna kind of get, you know, like it's great that you golf with that
person, but that should not be why
we sell with you.
It should be because it's the best solution for the customer
and, and our models and our statistical models can
take the best of things that you do and
recommend you into the right customer customer opportunities
because everyone wins in that in that scenario.
That's the goal,
and we're well on the way.
So this all sounds fine, but you might be thinking, well, Matt,
what are you gonna do about my
massive business operations team to support my marketplace
operations and, and and partner
operations? I have an Ace team. How many of you have an Ace
team? Yeah,
they're, they're kind of shy.
So the goal is, is, you know,
I love Ace, don't get me wrong, like I own Ace,
but um,
you shouldn't have to have a whole Ace team,
you know, we wanna help those people be way more efficient just
like you shouldn't have to have a whole private offer team.
Those people could be out there selling those people could
be out there building solutions, right?
They're highly educated, super talented
cloud people that should be out there in front of customers building
solutions. So the goal here is to
help the, help your AC team, help the marketplace
operations team be highly efficient, help us all.
Maybe go home for the weekend early on Friday.
Get to that replay party.
So right now we have a very healthy
self-service business. In fact, over 80% of all
transactions in the marketplace are self-service.
Even though like the big deals
that we're doing with our friends at Salesforce or with CrowdStrike
or Dabricks, like the large private offers with our
largest sellers, those tend to be custom priced
private offers.
But there's this huge thick middle.
What about all those deals for customers who would
typically qualify for some kind of a discount?
But, and, and they're kind of too
small to maybe put a big sales team against them.
Think of like a $10,000 maybe depending on the
size of your company,
$10,000 might be a lot or, or a little.
Let's say $10,000 50,000 dollars deal.
You're not gonna have a whole enterprise sales team around a $50,000
deal. Maybe you will, but.
You don't want to necessarily from a cost of sales
perspective, right?
And it's pretty predictable. What if it's like a 2
year renewal with a 5% uplift and the terms
haven't changed
and nothing else has changed? Like,
do you really need a very smart, expensive
salesperson to negotiate that?
No. You know that that's gonna qualify
for like a 15% discount off your standard rate
card. So tell
us that
that's what Express Private offers is.
You set the parameters. You say, listen,
contract duration X,
country Y,
customer Z,
if they meet these criteria, give them this discount,
no human involved.
That's Express Private Offers.
It automates private pricing.
Private pricing as a service.
We're not gonna stop there, but this is not a roadmap session,
but we're starting with pricing. But there are other parts
that perhaps we could automate
in these kind of thick middle deals.
We're just getting started here. This is super exciting.
Because some customers
demand private pricing, whether
they want to feel special or they actually qualify for it, but it doesn't
matter, you want to make that sale,
so we
can help automate that and reduce the cost of sales
and reduce the operational burden.
While delivering the right discounts or whatever you want
to deliver to customers.
By the way, I should have said that um.
We use AI in that too.
So we actually use AI to qualify the customer because
it's important
for you to feel confident that you set
the parameters. You're 100% in control with private offers.
And but you need to know that that person's saying,
hey, you know, I'm from Amazon. Like, are you? So we
use AI to actually qualify that the customer is who they
say they are and that they meet your criteria before
we issue that private offer on your behalf with Express
Private offers. That's how it works.
Variable payments is also one of those ones that maybe
not the most exciting title. I should have come up
with a better feature name for that, but one
of the most exciting,
uh, features if you're selling professional services on
Marketplace, little known fact, 10,000 out of
the 30,000 listings on Marketplace are professional
services listings.
But anyone who has a professional services listening may
tell you that they were only so useful
because we didn't support time and materials like milestone-based
pricing, value-based pricing.
Now we do.
That's what variable payments is,
which is super important for multi-product solutions
because now you can have a time and materials-based
professional services offering combined with software
wrapped into a multi-product solution.
Think of the possibilities.
International growth, um,
this is an area where we have made huge
progress over the last couple of years. Up here on stage, I
think I was apologizing a couple of years ago for international
and now I'm not apologizing anymore. I think it's actually our, our
strength. We're doing really well here. We can
save you money.
Uh, we, we rolled out a number of different
currencies, and this isn't just like FX conversion.
In fact, it's the opposite.
Uh, we actually have local entities in most of the
world's major markets now, which means that we can do local
bills with with local taxation,
and you can issue the private offer end to end
in euro or Great British pound or yen or
Korean won
or Australian dollar.
Uh, so these are actually
full.
Internationalization, full local tax compliance
like withholding tax compliance, VAT compliance.
Though sometimes some countries the bill has to look a certain
way or else it just doesn't work.
We actually had to spend engineering effort to move where the VAT
number was on invoices or like it wouldn't go through.
But this sounds crazy, but there's some of you who
understand that if you don't get this right,
it blocks a deal.
So we do a ton of undifferentiated
heavy lifting to make
international work and we save you
money because if you transact end to end
in euro, you don't have to backhaul it back to
the US for example, you don't pay for that currency
conversion. And you know you have to wait
To get dispersed until we collect, right?
What happens if the currency goes down
from, you know, the time of purchase to disbursement
that, that has burned a lot of people and so we remove
that by doing end to end transactions in
local currencies. This is a huge differentiator.
And if you know, you know,
if you're, if you're dealing with this, you'll know this is a really big
deal. Uh, we could support 2% transactions
in Brazil
to get around some, some local tax curiosities
in that country.
Uh, India, we just launched, uh, Japan, we,
we released some new things like Japanese consumption
tax support which is very important if you're doing
business in Japan,
Australian dollar, euro,
uh, it's all very exciting.
International is definitely an area of
strength of marketplace now
and not just from the US out
also into the US we have partners like Datamask
who's a very nice CEO
who are bagging huge deals in the US
uh from
New Zealand
and it's amazing that you can have startups outside of the US
getting huge enterprise deals in Europe, in the
US, etc. so it works in both directions.
We got to move faster.
So we're gonna move quickly.
So we get to deployment though. So what about um
what happens after you subscribe? I, I said this is so
important. It's especially important in agents.
In July, I mentioned we launched the AI agents
and tools marketplace.
Getting to value as a customer is critical,
and with agents,
it's uh it's one thing to find the agent, but
if you get, for example, that elastic MCP
server from the Accenture multi-product solution.
How do you start to use it and how do you use it securely?
So we support Bedrock Agent Corp
for our new AI agents and tools category, which
by the way has ballooned to over 2000 listings
now. You can discover both MCP enabled
agents
and agentic tools and professional services
for agent implementation,
but for the agents themselves, the MCP agents,
the API-based agents, what one feature
that I don't wanna overlook that's super important
is we let customers deploy the agents
directly from marketplace
into Agent core runtime.
And this is important for a couple of reasons. It can protect
the partner IP
but allows the customers now with Agent Corres supporting
VPC
to run those containerized agents securely within
Agent Corre runtime.
So it allows those agents to scale, to be secure,
and to be set up for use immediately after
purchase. So increasingly
so many of you in the room are thinking
your CIO or CTO is saying, what is your agentic strategy?
You're building agents like crazy now you can
sell them to customers through the marketplace and allow
those customers to use them securely more
quickly by marketplace's deep integration
with Agent Corp runtime
and gateway.
But not everything is agents yet.
There's still a lot of sass out there. That's what I'm told.
It's still the majority
of, of what we're doing on marketplace and so that's why we
have a new feature called IAM temporary delegation.
You probably know what this means inherently,
you know, you probably have a calendar application and you
might have another application that wants read only access to
your calendar for whatever reason
and then you know there's a pop-up that says, do you give this
application access to your calendar? That's kind of what I
am temporary delegation is. It says, hey, do
you give partner X temporary
access to your account to do to set up the
application? This lets our partners set up
sophisticated setup workflows
so they can set things up, hook up AWS services
to their product, so you, your customer can get
value out of that product right away.
We also have a managed version of this, which is what we launched
last year with Data bricks and this year with CrowdStrike,
which does a guided step walkthrough.
That sets the customer up after they make
the purchase.
So if you have a SAS application, you can use the
you can use IM temporary delegation to
reduce churn and to increase time
to value.
For example, there needs to be like a redshift cluster hooked up to
the SAS application.
You can do that on behalf of the customer automatically
using IM temporary delegation.
I made the joke already,
uranium 3 and graviton 5
have nothing on PC 3.
This is a big deal.
Partner Central
has moved to the AWS console. It's a big deal because
it's not just moving into the console.
That would be hard but not good enough. It's
also a whole set of awesome APIs.
They'll have MCP servers and and
soon agents associated with them.
If you've worked with Ace and with Partner Central
or you've ever asked for funding,
now you can do it programmatically.
The benefits API is one of the sleeper huge hits
here. Now you can make a funding request
and get that, get those credits allocated right
away without having to pick up the phone and call Julia.
And that's huge. I mean, Julia is amazing. I, I love. I'll
call Julia every day of the week, but it's a much more
scalable way to run your business. You can build
opportunities,
uh, send in leads
all over, uh, you know, restful APIs
and MCP servers.
You can create solutions in Parts Central. You
can make those funding requests. You can find
other partners through the connections API. We have a
fully programmable stack, and
it's in the console and it's an ADBS service now,
so you can wrap it in fine-grained IAM permissions.
So that alliance leads, should they be allowed to apply for funding?
Maybe not.
The finance team can have a separate set of fine-grain
access controls to use the benefits API.
So you can just like you can with other AWBS services,
you can define who does what in a much more
powerful way.
Partner revenue measurement in my 10 seconds left here
because I got excited and went over.
It is very important because it allows you,
the partner,
to send in telemetry to us to tell us
how your product is actually
having impact on the customer accounts and increasingly
we're going to start to think how can we model incentives
around the true direct and indirect impact
that your product drives.
So this is very important, especially if you're a services
partner, a professional services, a consulting partner
or an ISB partner. It's critical that
you start to understand what PRM
or partner revenue measurement is.
This is telemetry. Instead of just guessing the
impact that we're having with the customers, you can prove.
The impact that you're having both direct and indirect so that
we can give you the right benefits and model the right incentives
for you, for our sellers,
and for the customers
according to the true holistic impact that you're driving.
So we're taking just like we did with Partner Central, a
programmatic approach to partnerships.
We're now taking a programmatic approach to measuring
the impact of our partnerships.
If you'd like to learn more about partner revenue measurement,
there's a private bid available.
I'm happy to hook you up with it. Just grab me after the session.
So I'm only a few seconds over.
To recap
AWS Marketplace,
we've been using AI since 2018 actually. That's
when Sagemaker Jumpstart, when our model marketplace
launched. But it's really hit its stride both
with our AI agents marketplace with over
2000 listings, but also how we use
AI to power all of the features that we covered.
Solution-based buying with multi-product solutions
and not stopping at subscribe. With IM
temporary delegation,
with uh Quick launch plus that we have for CrowdStrike
and Data bricks,
we're doing more to help you increase,
increase conversion but also increase retention and renewal
rates with after you buy.
And then PC Partner Central 3.0,
uh, a very exciting way to fully automate,
lower your total cost of operations, and ultimately
move faster because really that's what we're trying to do,
right? We're trying to serve customers faster,
do more for them in a better way.
So we're here for you. I'd love your feedback.
Um, I would love next year to say, remember when I said how excited
I was, that was nothing.
Like I said, we shipped 27% more features this year.
We were 31% more efficient thanks to AI and
my own engineering team. I think we can maybe do
50% more features next year, but which ones we build
is up to you. So I welcome your feedback. And one
way you can give us your feedback
is like this, it really does help. So please take a moment
to give feedback. But thanks for your time today. I
I really do appreciate you coming on Thursday night
and see you on the dance floor later.